معدل الادخار الأمريكي هو في الواقع
ضعف الوقت
الذي كان عليه في العام الماضي ، لذا فإن
الأصول المالية للأسرة الأمريكية
تبلغ حوالي 15 ، لذا ضعف المبلغ
الذي تم
الاحتفاظ به في العام الماضي نقدًا ، ونرى أرصدة
تقترب في الواقع من 25 إلى 30
في
المائة وأعتقد أن أكبر شيء هو
حقًا فكرة
كيف يمكنني توظيف رأس المال للعمل في هذه
البيئة عندما يبدو كل شيء
مكلفًا ،
كيف يمكنني التغلب على هذه العقبة
النقدية أشعر بالأمان وأعتقد أن هناك
شيئين يجب أخذهما في الاعتبار.  الأول
هو أنه مع المخاوف التضخمية
ومعدلات التضخم المتوقعة
إذا كنت تقدم نقدًا ، فمن الواضح
أنه أمر عقابي ، إنه شيء سيفقد قيمته ،
والشيء الآخر هو أنني أعتقد أنه إذا أخذنا
القليل من درس التاريخ
فيما يتعلق بالعودة إلى أم.
بالعودة إلى البيئة السابقة ، فإنه
يذكرنا بالكثير من عام 2009 ،
لذا خرجنا من
الأزمة المالية العالمية التي كانت أزمة نظامية حقيقية
وليست صدمة خارجية مثل
كوفيد ، وإذا نظرنا إلى  هـ -
أظهرت عائدات الأسهم الأمريكية في عام 2009
عائدًا بنحو 27 وكان حوالي 42
خارج الولايات المتحدة وما حدث أن
الكثير من الأشخاص نقلوا أصولهم إلى
نقد
وقالوا إنني لم أعد هذه هي نهاية
هذا  التعافي
وما رأيناه منذ ذلك الحين هو أن
عائدات الأسهم غير الأمريكية تزيد عن 400 في المائة كانت عائدات حقوق الملكية غير الأمريكية تزيد
عن 250 في المائة ،
وحققنا عوائد حقوق ملكية عالمية إيجابية في
تسعة من الأعوام الـ 11 التالية
، وفي حين أن السيولة قد تكون عادت بنحو
ستة في المائة
عندما  ننظر إلى ذلك على أساس تضخمي
معدل ،
فهو في الواقع سالب 14 في المائة ، لذلك
عندما نرى هذه التراجعات والأسواق
بعد الركود بعد التراجع ، فهي في
الواقع بداية دورة اقتصادية جديدة
وليست نهاية
[موسيقى]